thank you
he's one of our new best friends he's
Marcus Spears the big swagu former NFL
defensive end and you can see him on NFL
live Monday through Friday at 4 Eastern
on ESPN they're out here in Scottsdale
catch the big swagu along with Laura
Rutledge Mina kimes Dan olowsky and Ryan
Clark let's say hello to Marcus big
swagoo Spears
damn that was too long I'm not that
interested
I don't know what that look is I don't
want the official well you gave me this
you gave me this big introduction man I
feel like this is my first like late
night talk show oh yeah do I need to
worry if you want to I might keep your
ears warm yeah I feel like I need to do
something like they do on The Late Night
show I'm good though all right I'm good
could you beat up all four of those guys
absolutely once throw them over that
rail you could yeah yeah get rid of them
one by one when's the last time you got
into a fight it's been a long time ago I
won though yeah he did yeah
they used to call me Tyson when I was
young Dan
because I was a one-hitter quitter
artist
oh that's it you know I used to show it
for Tyson fights and you excited when
you have like 30 seconds in you realize
you wasted 200 yes that was it that was
me why would somebody fight you because
they the big guy always gets tested
but when when I tell you this when MMA
and UFC started that's when I stopped
fighting
because the little dudes can fight
you don't know who you're dealing with
anymore man well I always look for the
ears yeah if the ears messed up run run
run but who's the baddest dude that you
ever played with or against the baddest
dude I ever played on on the field like
the guy might have scared you a little
bit made you nervous he was on my team
Larry Allen okay yeah I mean obviously
he wasn't human that's number one which
changes everything about your advantages
um he was strong I was a rookie he was a
veteran he wanted me to buy him a bottle
of Louis the 13th I had no idea what
that was didn't know what it cost I went
to the I went to the liquor store
um can we can we talk about alcohol on
here yeah I'm sure we can I already
started yeah uh went to the liquor store
I realized it was 2500 for a bottle went
back to the locker room DP had no idea
what was going to happen to me because I
didn't buy the bottle
twenty five hundred dollars I couldn't
really compute that at the time I was
still fresh out of Baton Rouge broke and
poor I hadn't realized I was in the NFL
so I was like bro I'm not buying that
bottle he was like you gonna buy that
bottle so it's like I'm not buying that
bottle uh and I told him I said whatever
you got to do it man really
it was like a jail situation
it's not happening I borrowed the money
to buy the bottle no Dan you sometimes
you got to put your foot down even if it
mean you might lose a foot
and what happened well we you know we
tussled we tussled that practice and it
wasn't uh
it wasn't as bad as I thought I lost but
it wasn't as bad as I thought
did you did you ask for any advice from
your teammates no this was all about me
you ever seen that movie that seen in
life when Eddie Murphy said he can't
have his cornbread it was the exact
thing it was
I I knew I was gonna have to fight and
it was fine it was good with me I grew
up fighting I wasn't you know I'm every
every man puts his puts his pants on the
same that's my mentality and I'm Noah
Dan trust me I'm a lover not a fighter
okay okay but if it got to go down it
can go down when when you play for the
Cowboys at what point do you realize
this is different than any other team
well you know the media coverage is just
different than everybody else
immediately man it is
I tell people all the time you that is
the biggest acclimation to playing with
Dallas
eventually football becomes football
right you practicing you got your
schedule you're going through it but to
to always have media literally always
have a microscope everywhere you go
um it's different and I I was happy when
I went to Baltimore because I got a
different experience of what what what
the different things were but I mean
it's no coincidence that that is the
most valuable franchise it's covered the
most uh ratings go through the roof when
people talk about them so it just you
realize though it's a 24 7 News cycle
about the Dallas Cowboys even if it's
not National somebody is having a
conversation about Dallas but
consciously subconsciously when you do
NFL live yeah how often are you trying
to get the Cowboys into the show every
day I'm not I try to get them in as
least as possible why personally okay
because they break my heart every day oh
okay um but if Dak Prescott played
someplace else yeah how would the media
cover his performance now they might
look at his contract and I don't know if
they treat him like they do Kirk Cousins
they wouldn't treat him as bad or we
wouldn't have that much conversation
look the reality is this this is not new
territory right for any quarterback
playing with Dallas I knew who Troy
Aikman was before I knew what football
was and I wasn't really I grew up a
Jerry Rice fan I was more of players
fans than a team so Reggie White and
Jerry Rice was the guys that I watch but
I knew who Troy Michael Irvin and Emma
Smith were because David Blaine went
there and did some magic tricks or not
and they had they had every every
microscope you could possibly have and
also they were winning which we haven't
done in a long time but we let's not get
into that Dan the I want to stay focused
on why the Cowboys or who they are they
they were marketed so you realize like
this is
this is reality show football all of
that stuff intertwined with with playing
the game because it feels like the
Cowboys are hard knocks every single day
100 100 you don't need a TV show they
are a TV show well look and then you
bring in Jerry who wants to be the owner
GM coach and quarterback he wants to be
everything yes Dan let me say this okay
some people might get pissed off
Jerry actually wants to win
he just don't know how
but if you talk to him
and you you realize how much he wants to
win a Super Bowl in the championship you
it'll get you going because it's not
it's not false when he talks about I
want to win it I want to get it done he
just don't know how to go about it
here's the problem though Jerry wants
all the credit yeah and and with that
comes all the blame as well if you move
on from Jimmy Johnson that tells me an
awful lot about uh he got a lot of
credit there have we ever talked about
okay
have we ever talked about maybe the
Cowboys are cursed
because of Jimmy Johnson you think Jimmy
cursed him I'm not a big baseball guy
all right but I like baseball all right
I'm not just not big because I'm not
following everything that happens in it
and you know they get to the
championship series I'll sit down and
watch it
the curse of the Bambino was a real
thing I thought
right and then the Red Sox won finally
finally
you telling me we're gonna have to wait
a damn 100 years
was it 100 years Dan but maybe you do a
sacrifice like burn Jimmy Johnson's Boat
or something well they do it to me every
day on TV I I'll be the sacrifice if it
means a Super Bowl by the way we're
talking to Marcus Spears the big swagu
you can see him Monday through Friday on
NFL live Dan orlovsky is uh gonna die on
that Hill that Joe Montana is not a top
five quarterback of all time yeah I
don't get it yeah I don't get it I don't
um I just don't get it but I wonder what
Brady's Legacy did to Joe Montana
because for such a long period of time
it was Joe yeah because he won his super
bowls and that was it but like you can't
drop from 1 to 18 or something I listen
Dan thinks he know everything y'all know
that y'all have him on all the time and
I gotta fight with him because he's the
quarterback Guru even though he didn't
play that much
um nah but honestly like that that's
me and Dan talk about football a lot and
and like truthfully I think he's one of
the best and brightest football Minds
I've ever been around when it comes to
Breaking the game down dissecting
um but to not have Joe Montana in the
top five quarterbacks is stupid
I don't know sometimes you have to
experience it you have to see that
person yeah I don't care to understand
their greatness I don't care I don't
care about seeing them I know he won
four Super Bowls
you could use orlovsky as a Q-tip you
know that arlovsky is little he looks
like a Q-tip so he told me yesterday he
came here with no jacket
yeah he said I didn't know he had hand
warmers and no jacket when he came in
here that is the exact definition
[Laughter]
what the NBA players do they took their
socks and they uh they they put their
pants in their socks yeah and in honor
of the KD trade and Brawn breaking the
scoring record I wanted to dress like
NBA player today
a lot of a lot of good stuff going on a
little shout out there yeah a little
shout out okay greatest team
you know it you know it he's got the
Travis Scott ones on I didn't buy them
but those things are Perfection yeah you
didn't buy them no all right so let me
find the plug I gotta get my I got to
give a shout out so Isabelle Harrison
okay Isabel Isabel WNBA star yeah okay
uh good friend of mine family friend my
wife and her older sister group like
played at LSU together we family she got
me these she's a Jordan athlete shout
out to easy okay okay Izzy shout out to
you I didn't mean to do that Marvin
you're not gonna get some free stuff I
didn't mean to plug that but it just
happened yeah
so
better team player resume
LeBron or Tom Brady
better team player resume like the
accomplishments over 20 plus years Brian
I think bro three teams three
championships three with three different
teams that's tough
that's tough to do DP well going to
Miami when they had Chris Bosh and
Dwyane Wade that ain't tough well they
didn't win it when he left
yeah but he's having him with Dwayne
Wade those are that's two other Hall of
Famers there I know and and I don't want
to get into this with you because I love
you and I like you a lot
we we act like we act like the teams
that Jordan played with the other dudes
around him was trash
y people damn near one League MVP when
Jordan retired they should have gone to
the NBA finals that Year Dennis Rodman
the Hall of Famer yeah people don't
respect Bill Carter writing Horace Grant
those were really good players Tony
cuckoo time cool coach BJ Armstrong yeah
we saw John Paxton and Steve Kerr hit
game winners everybody acts like Ron was
the first one to play with great players
we saw a mass Exodus to Houston Charles
Barkley was 900 years old
Mike didn't leave to hook up with other
players because they came there but they
tried they drafted them oh it's okay Dan
they were in Chicago first of all how
many times you how many times have you
got on the radio and said you know what
I'm gonna go hoop in Cleveland
well I'm from Ohio no I'm saying how
many times have you said I'm going to go
hoop in Cleveland probably never okay
and you and you from Ohio yeah okay but
but I always think of LeBron you said
Cleveland Cavalier he is yeah he is yeah
and and and the Lakers won't be his last
team and the legacy is this too the way
he was treated when he left Cleveland we
don't give him credit for going back
don't get me started on LeBron I love
the guy I know I do too I think he's the
greatest player of all time right he
went back and delivered a trip but Tom
Brady's resume to me yeah is more
impressive because Brady plays in a
one-and-done playoff system when it's
harder it's harder I argue this with
Kendrick Perkins all the time it's
harder to win the Super Bowl yes yeah
but if you got one bad game you're out
if LeBron has one bad game against the
Celtics you can come back and you got
they got to beat you three more times
100 all right so are we okay but LeBron
got to play defense and offense well
I've seen him sometime he doesn't play
any defense that's okay what a chase
down Tom
Dan let's not do it Andre godella I know
but but sometimes Tom plays great
defense by playing great offense to keep
his defense off the field sure does yeah
touche how about that man we are not
going to see how to when Dan won and Tim
I mean when tomorrow morning Tampa you
think the defense was more responsible
at offense in the Super Bowl defense all
right well bye
how about the whole seat how about the
totality of the sea why it was the
number one defense don't make don't make
me go Larry Allen on you let's make you
go to the liquor stores
like I told him you can get thrown over
the rail too
hahaha
do you want to talk about the Super Bowl
if you want to
we can do whatever you want better
defensive line
Philly
um complete you can't you can't you
can't you can't say that I'm gonna give
all this attention to Hassan ready
because Joshua to hit your quarterback
in the back of the head
Javon Hargrave Fletcher Cox and
dominicansu had a Revival he's starting
to rush to pass at a high level
um but they brought him in probably to
shore up the running game yeah um and
then we saw him put a quarterback out
the second quarterback from San
Francisco I think I think when it comes
to Philly man the difficult part for
Andy Reid and Eric being and me going
into this game is figuring out how to
protect not not if because if you guys
can't block them one-on-one it don't
matter anyway right but how do you
allocate
you like that word I'm starting to like
I'm starting to like learn some
Financial stuff like how do you allocate
resources
you like that well it's got to pay
dividends it's got to pay dividends yeah
yeah you got to allocate resources to to
making sure you get these guys blocked
up and I really think the only way you
do it is obviously getting the ball out
of pet hands quick and Andy frustrated
the hell out of me against Cincinnati
because he he kind of just flippantly
ran the football out of shotgun you
better figure out how to use Pacheco to
keep these dudes from pinning their ears
back and taking advantage of your
offensive line and the chief's offensive
line is good they protected well uh is
Patrick Mahomes a top 10 quarterback of
all time right now yeah
I believe he I truly believe he is I
believe that Patrick Mahomes retired
today he'll be in the Hall of Fame
do you believe that Aaron Rodgers would
not retire this year because he doesn't
want to share the Hall of Fame Spotlight
with Tom Brady and JJ Watt I mean
everything I've seen about Aaron Rodgers
tells me he don't want to share the
spotlight with JJ Watt and Tom Brady he
won his own dark room Hall of Fame
ceremony
have you ever gone into a dark room for
four days to get clarity
no I don't know how that works Darkness
to me means death
I ain't trying to die there
wow it's just that simple we just got
deep there hey man but what happens when
you walk into the room and it's dark can
I I can't find the chair I can't find
the like if I want to go to sleep okay
yeah I go in a dark room and then I wake
up and I go outside
because the sun is good for you if you
but would you take anything personally
when you faced a quarterback let me ask
you a question all right here we go let
me ask you a question
why is it always filthy rich people that
do dumps
you know what I'm saying
I don't I I I grew up poor people don't
Skydive I grew up in Baton Rouge okay my
mom worked hard my dad worked hard we
didn't have a lot of money we didn't
have a lot of allocated resources okay
okay
you might have been in a dark room not
by your choice but that's what I'm
saying they were going through a lot
trying to raise me and my sister get us
the events and sports and try to get us
to school and do our work well that's a
high stress level right while being
broke
they never needed a retreat in a dark
room for clarity
it's like when you it's all the rich
people they oh I'm gonna go sit in a
room for four days bro you got fit you
made 50 million dollars this year turn
the lights off in your damn house and
sit in there for four days
why do you have to pay to go someplace
fly someplace to sit in a dark room I
don't get it Dan there's certain things
about life I don't understand why rich
people get free stuff molding pole
people you just pointed out you got free
stuff that's what I'm saying I'm
benefiting from it I'm not gonna say no
don't give me the Travis Scott do you
have rich people problems no I will be
though
oh it's great to see you and thanks for
joining us all the uh appearances during
the year we always got a great reaction
and uh we we appreciate that thank you
brother thank you for having me man
Marcus Spears the big swagu you can see
him uh he'll be here for Eastern in uh
old uh old Old Town Scottsdale Old Town
Scottsdale baby all right got me any
kind I saw you pushing her around
yesterday on this set yeah she tried to
play guard she too light not enough
rocks Laura Rutledge Mina kimes Dan
olowski and Ryan Clark we'll be back we
got our play of the day after this Dan
Patrick Show